en este segmento de invitado del día lo
vamos a dedicar a analizar los sucesos
más importantes de este 2022 y hacemos
un repaso general de todos los
acontecimientos antes de nuestro receso
por la festividades de diciembre hoy
hablamos de las protestas en Irán y el
rol protagónico de las mujeres y jóvenes
que manifiestan contra el régimen y que
también piden el fin de las políticas
fundamentalistas que rigen su código de
vestimenta se lo vamos entonces a Marta
González Isidro ella es periodista y
analista política especialista en
Oriente medio Gracias Marta por estar
con nosotros esta mañana de martes en
directo América de Francia 24 y hagamos
un un balance general no una radiografía
general de la situación actual en Irán
de cara en estas protestas contra el
régimen
Hola buenos días Bueno yo creo que
después de tres de tres meses ya de
protestas podemos hacer un balance en el
que a mí me parece que se está
despertando a nivel internacional una
ilusión de cambio en el régimen
iraní que no se corresponde con la
realidad a pesar de que las protestas y
las imágenes que nos llegan a diario a
través de las televisiones y de las de
las de los medios de comunicación parece
que es lo que lo que lo que parece
es difícil pensar como digo que se vaya
a producir un cambio de régimen a pesar
de la violencia con la que se están
produciendo estas estas
revueltas porque estamos hablando de un
régimen que está sustentado en una
ideología en una interpretación
religiosa y por está sustentado o está
sostenido por la por las haría es decir
lo que empezó como unas protestas
amparadas en una en un ansia de libertad
y en mejores derechos y con el fondo del
velo como un catalizador de un cambio
más profundo en realidad lo que estamos
viendo Es una diferencia
abismal entre el estado y la sociedad
que va más allá de la Constitución de
una vestimenta de las formas de una
vestimenta o de cambio de una de una
vestimenta de una vestimenta y de usos y
costumbres tradicionales Lo que sí es
cierto Marta que hemos visto este rol o
protagónico de las mujeres no en este
intento por tratar de de cambiar las
cosas no como ve digamos
evolución de que han tenido sobre todo
las jóvenes iraníes hasta este punto
porque unos años atrás capaz esto era
casi impensable por todo este miedo de
la represión una represión brutal como
la que hemos visto en en todas las
imágenes que nos llegan desde Irán pero
que parece que las jóvenes ya le han
perdido como un poco el miedo no a toda
esta represión por parte del gobierno
le han perdido el miedo y lo que estamos
viendo Efectivamente es ese divorcio
entre el estado que está constituido por
un régimen fundamentalista islámico y
una sociedad o unos jóvenes que
responden realmente a todo lo que está
pasando en el resto de oriente medio y
es una población cada vez más más joven
más divorciada de los paradigmas
tradicionales que han conformado las
políticas tradicionales de oriente medio
y que quieren unas mejoras en sus en su
vida no solamente en los usos y
costumbres que no tienen nada que ver
con la que crearon o las constituciones
que crearon sus mayores sino también en
unas formas de
vida que tienen que ver más con mejoras
sociales políticas económicas más
parecidas a los cambios que también que
se aprecian a través de las redes
sociales y que ven que en occidente y
que en otros países del Mundo viven de
forma
satisfactoria No En ese sentido sí
podemos ver que los jóvenes han perdido
el miedo pero como repito pero repito
estamos hablando de un régimen que tiene
todavía
unas unos lazos a través de la
Constitución muy definidos unas
instituciones muy fuertes unos vínculos
a nivel geopolítico también muy
definidos por lo tanto
creo que va a ser muy complicado que el
régimen tal y como está definido caiga
otra cosa es que
hemos visto a lo largo de estos años que
en diferentes ocasiones y también
dependiendo de el presidente del
gobierno el Primer Ministro pertenece a
la facción más moderada o más radical
más religiosa radical se han producido
avances o sea flexibilizado las normas
de conducta que repito están recogidas
en la Constitución lo que sí podemos ver
a partir de ahora es que haya una una
flexibilización de los códigos de
vestimenta que afectan no solamente a
las mujeres sino también a los hombres y
eso podría ser una ventana de
oportunidad a un régimen que hoy no está
en riesgo pero podría
Marta en su opinión en que pueden acabar
todas estas manifestaciones en Irán qué
podemos ver los próximos días los
próximos semanas meses
pues lo que estamos viendo Es una
continuación
de la radicalización del régimen de las
formas de presión contra la sociedad y
sobre todo contra los sectores que son
que son más proclives abrir y abrir
brecha en un régimen fundamentalista
estamos viendo como hay cerca de 450
muertos y son
los sectores precisamente más dinámicos
más aperturistas más progresistas las
mujeres universitarias los cantantes los
representantes de la sociedad de los
sectores culturales los que se están
viendo más reprimidos y yo creo que es
lo que vamos a ver en los próximos días
en los próximos meses una continuación
de la represión al tiempo que en el
parlamento se van a se van a no
solamente el uso obligatorio del velo
sino también otras formas de apertura
que den salida a las
salida a reivindicaciones de carácter
social y económico de los sectores más
aperturistas de la sociedad para evitar
precisamente que caiga el régimen